Speaker 1: All right. Let's talk about an
incredible story that's both incredible for
what it contains, but also because of some of the
reaction that we've seen from some. The Pentagon
has admitted to killing 10 civilians, including
up to seven children in a Kabul drone strike
last month. This particular drone strike was
the center of much controversy because it tied
in with the withdrawal from Afghanistan that
Donald Trump initially said he wanted to do,
wasn't able to do, and Joe Biden ultimately
did. We now have video of a CENTCOM commander,
General Kenneth Mackenzie, saying we
didn't get terrorists, we got civilians.
The U.S. is considering reparation payments to
surviving family members. The Pentagon originally
said the strike killed two ISIS fighters believed
to be involved in planning attacks against U.S.
forces in Kabul. The drone strike came after a
suicide bomb attack by ISIS KIA that resulted in
the deaths of 13 U.S. service members and dozens
of Afghans near Kabul's airport. So we're going to
look at video of General Kenneth Mackenzie saying,
I apologize for this. And then there's a few
different things that I want to talk about. But
to go into it, to kind of frame this, the reason
this particular drone strike is getting so much
attention is the context in the withdrawal from
Afghanistan as retaliation to the ISIS suicide
bombing near the airport that left 13 service
members and more civilians dead. Let's listen.
Speaker 2: I am now convinced that as many as 10
civilians, including up to seven children,
were tragically killed in that strike.
Moreover, we now assess that it is unlikely that
the vehicle and those who died were associated
with ISIS or were a direct threat to U.S. forces
Speaker 1: so far
killed civilians didn't kill ISIS.
Speaker 2: OK, I offer my profound
condolences to the family and friends of those who
were killed. This strike was taken and the earnest
belief that it would prevent an imminent threat to
our forces and the evacuees at the airport. But it
was a mistake. And I offer my sincere apology as
the combatant commander, I am fully responsible
for this strike and this tragic outcome.
Speaker 1: So it seems. Incongruous
to be talking about a strike which was supposed
to get ISIS okay, but got 10 civilians,
including seven children and saying, I'm sorry,
guys, sorry we didn't get the terrorists, we got
10 civilians. And I get that it's completely
incongruous. It's like visually shocking.
Am I really hearing this? Is this how they're
talking about it? This happens all the time.
This particular drone strike got more attention
because of the circumstances surrounding it. We've
been talking about the issue of drone strikes
killing civilians for a decade. I mean, we
started really talking about it in earnest under
Barack Obama. The drone program under the Obama
administration was one of the biggest foreign
policy criticisms of the Obama administration.
Genk Yuga, our friend from the Young Turks,
had a nice series of tweets about pointing to
this outrage. It may or may not be real. The
media outrage in response to this admission
from the from the CENTCOM commander. But it's
actually another data point of the media being
against the Afghanistan withdrawal. Genk explains
it. Let's look at these tweets Genk wrote, quote,
All the reporters who are outraged by
Pentagon drone strike that killed civilians.
Are you guys not aware that we've been killing
civilians with drone strikes for decades?
How is this news to you that you are all of a
sudden bothered by it because almost none of you
objected before going on to say, interestingly,
this outrage comes as a continuation of corporate
media rage over the withdrawal from a war.
This outrage did not at all exist in the middle
of those wars, but now, quote, Reporters are
pissed that the Pentagon makes mistakes. Please,
Jenckes is spot on here. It is great that
the Pentagon has taken responsibility for
something horrifying. OK, it's great that they're
considering payments, payments, which, of course,
don't bring family back. But what else can
you do now other than get throw money at a
problem? Right. But this isn't new and there is
a very cynical nature to this. And it's analogous
to the media reaction to the withdrawal from
Afghanistan. As I've said before, the withdrawal
was 100 percent the right thing to do. Had Trump
done, it would have been extremely complicated.
Similar things would have happened.
Biden did. It got us out of a war.
There has been more criticism from the media,
corporate, centrist media and right wing media
and even left wing media to some degree of Biden
getting out. There's been more scrutiny of Biden
getting out than there was of the 20 years
that we spent there. And in the same way,
it's not that this drone strike is irrelevant.
It's it's horrifying. It's a tragedy. It's should
it be criminal, right? I mean, OK, there's no
mitigation about this particular drone strike,
but it's being used by some in the media
to further reinforce the idea that leaving
Afghanistan was a mistake when if they cared about
drone strikes, they could have been covering the
drone war for the last decade differently
than they did. And they haven't been doing
it. And so it's hard to take it all seriously.
Good for Genk for pointing this out. Good that
they took responsibility on video in this way.
But this is not a new thing that doesn't change
the seriousness of this particular drone strike.
But we've got to understand this in context and
understand the way in which it's useful to the
people that are reporting on it in certain ways